I'm just telling you bro I would never
get on a boat I don't know man those
linebackers coming at you they want to
hit you the bulls just trying to throw
me off how's it going man nice to meet
you nice to meet you too my huge fan bro
hey like Bonds no doubt
so I'm from Texas although I've never
been on a horse I've never been on a
bull I don't even own a pair of cowboy
boots we can change all of those things
alright it's 2011 it's my third year in
the NFL I'm balling right now it's a
third quarter I got like six passes
under my belt I catch a ball an angler
out and I put my hand on the ground like
this and my elbow pops out of socket and
my tricep tears off and my arm is like
dangling behind my back tore my tricep
had to go on IR the whole year missed
the whole season it's my sophomore year
of high school we were at this big
finals and I've got stepped on in my
calf well he doesn't think much about it
I mean it's bull ride and you know bumps
bruises you go on with it
my calf was just as big around as a
balloon they went in cut my calf open on
both sides from my knee all the way down
to my ankle to relieve all this pressure
sitting there in the hospital room for
you know those five to seven days you
think a lot well I do I do this the pros
the ridin bulls is always gonna outweigh
the cons for me and you know no matter
how much danger or how much pain I have
to deal with this is the life for me
bull rider was like being tough is just
a prerequisite I would rather get hit by
a linebacker every single day then get
bucked off a bull or stepped on the
stepped on is the bad one for sure I
would much rather get hit by a
linebacker they'd get stomped on by you
get hit by an 1800 pound animal but with
baseball bats on his head you know what
I read sometimes I get hit I got spit
and boogers all over my helmet and my
mouthpiece falls out and I'm
weten nobody cares man like we got the
next play to run we got a score we got
to get a first down that's the
commonality and both of our sports we're
trying to win a championship and we're
trying to be the best we get our ass
kicked that's what the commonality yeah
exactly I mean a lot of people let the
moment be bigger than them and I think a
man or woman just deep down have to just
absolutely crave that moment in sport
there's a lot of hard times like you
said I mean there there's a lot of pain
there's a lot of heartache there's a lot
of frustration to me you can't even
compare the two that heartache and then
the euphoria you get whenever you do
something that's truly incredible that
there's just a fraction of a percent of
people in the world that could do
something like that no question it's all
about sacrifice really like you said man
if you want to be the best at what you
do you got to put everything you have
into it for us it's our training it's
our nutrition and our season is 22 weeks
long which we get a half a day off a
week and then we're at the building for
10 to 12 hours every single day and
you've worked your whole life just to
have this opportunity right like yeah
it's not the 16 days a year it's the 16
years that nobody even saw for me being
a bull rider I'm on the road 200 220
days out of the year that that's a lot
of times that you lose with the people
that you love right you know there's a
lot of sleepless nights a lot of early
mornings yeah I guess the reason why we
do this is you know we want to win we
want to be the best we want to break
boundaries you know we want to be a
champion it's really been a pleasure to
talk to you to see what your body's gone
through and I have the utmost respect
it's awesome I couldn't agree more it's
always good to get to sit down with
somebody at the top of their game and
compare some scars for sure good luck
man
[Music]
[Applause]